for ladies gentlemen how important is it
income
for your man how important is
that your man
brings home the bacon how important is
that a scale of one to ten ten being
like oh my man better bring home the
bacon and one being like i don't know
you know i'll take care of my man and
then gentlemen you're next um for me
personally it's you have to meet me at
least halfway or higher okay no but like
so if you're making a hundred grand you
would not date a guy that makes 40 grand
i want to be able to grow from you so
the answer is no yeah okay
but a girlfriend amber i hold the people
that i date to the same standard that i
hold myself and i am currently on a
grind and i am not making money but i am
pursuing my passion and i have a lot of
energy and you can't look at me and say
that i don't work hard i want somebody
who works hard and even if they're not
there yet if i believe that there's
somewhere we can grow and they have
dreams and passion and work ethic then i
don't it's not a requirement for me so
income is not a requirement okay i need
to connect with somebody that is the
number one thing okay you want a guy
with ambition though absolutely we
talked about this uh
ambitious
gentlemen how important is income
a woman's income to you guys
mcdonald's we don't care
yeah i mean yeah personally i i don't
really care
if she's you know making 100 grand or
you know 10 grand what about the
personality that comes with that though
yeah i mean that's that's going to be a
little bit more important as far as like
is she you know useful or get off the
couch okay hold on but stay there you
don't care what they make or what they
do at all
no i mean
like you as far as like just strictly
financially yeah no i don't care okay
you no have you ever lived with a woman
i have you have lived with a woman i was
married for a year you were okay i've
had some long-term relationships i can
tell you this i've dated i mean we all
live in miami there's very attractive
people i've dated some pretty attractive
people there's nothing
uh more unattractive than a pretty girl
who sits her ass home all day and does
enough sure yeah okay i've been like all
right you were hot for a little while
now it's like what'd you do today no i
just kind of like laid out by the pool
it's like i've been grinding my ass off
like like cold calling all day
like at the very least did you cook
dinner no i can't really cook it's like
hold on yeah like she's useless so so at
some point maybe income doesn't matter
but bringing value matter you're not
just trying to hang yeah you're a smart
dude bro you're not just trying to hang
out with the bimbo and we talk about
that we talked about that on our planet
i think about a lot because a lot of
girls ask one of the times i learned a
lot is why why do i get ghosted and i
say yeah if a woman gets ghosted it's
not the man's fault it's the woman's
fault she didn't add value she didn't
add value
she was useless or she didn't bring
peace or whatever it may be but a lot of
women tend to blame men for getting
ghosted the reality is
guy game is game attaining the girl girl
game is retaining the guy after you [ __ ]
him and unfortunately many modern day
women can't do that because they think
let me just show up you know throw them
some box here there be pretty etcetera
and that's enough and yeah that'll be
enough to maybe get flown out go on a
trip here or there whatever it is and
get some sexual attention from high
value men but that does not mean that
you're going to get relationship
relationship type attention and that's
where i think the disconnect is